dans l'océan indien la réunion cherche
toujours à circonscrire l'épidémie de
chikungunya la maladie transmise par le
moustique toucherait plus de 150
personnes par jour depuis le début de
l'année ce genre de grippe n'est pas
mortel mais cause fièvre et douleurs
articulaires sur plusieurs semaines
le ci habite le quartier du petit brûlé
à sainte-rose sa cour est on ne peut
plus propre sans aucune réserve d'eau
qui peut devenir un nid à moustiques
pourtant lui si comme beaucoup
d'habitants du secteur a attrapé le
chikungunya la ravine située au bout de
son jardin
il y est certainement pour quelque chose
j'ai commencé par les douleurs les vents
de mon lit je n'arrivais plus à marcher
c'était tout le côté gauche après droit
des poussées de fièvre 40 à quelques
centaines de mètres de là habite jean
claude le fils de lucie âgée de 42 ans
est un sportif accompli qui a terminé
cette année 472e du grand raid
il ya peu de fièvre et après des
douleurs et ensuite j'ai demandé à mon
responsables des partis regroupements de
médecins et la presta grave et il fait
beaucoup plus mal géré articulations le
soir impossible de dormir correctement
c'était très très dur seule solution
pour lui si jean claude et les milliers
de réunionnais atteint par le
chikungunya l'europe au complet
puisqu'il n'existe pas pour l'instant
d'autres remèdes